[Music]
twenty-eight years ago okay
when I was just starting out in this
business and I was had just come to LA
and was working as a TV writer someone
came up to me and said hey we're
shooting this thing we'll pay you next
to nothing do you want to do it it was
for the National Association of music
merchants Oh sounds funny yeah so ladies
and gentleman here's me 28 years ago and
I apologize our success on your terms
improv players have selected several
very difficult customer types that may
come into your store let's look first at
the opinionated type of customer hi how
are you joy plans not going to open I
get to see you likewise six string
guitar hey I got a beautiful guitar for
you check this one out hey wait a minute
I'm not so sure about this this has got
a fiberoptic body I don't think I want
that
well it's a fiberoptic body but let me
tell you this thing is solid spruce I
don't know about the balance on this
thing they don't even use anymore the
spreads even making apartment now these
frets were laid in after production you
can see they use the chisel head well
yeah but use it sugar love that yeah
smell that snow that is that smell like
this no a topical here disaster you say
not at all just use the appropriate
strategy and turn the situation around
this isn't a solid spruce top trust me
really is good quality and you know I do
respect your your your knowledge back
guitars
I can't get over feelings but my voice
is the main it's absolutely horrific